joining us in the studio is Professor
yoke Duda an expert on the biomechanics
of the spine and its regeneration now
we've heard it's quite important to move
and to strengthen the deep muscles of
the spine but if you had a lumbago if
you suffered from a lumbago you don't
want to move so what do you do that's
true so so you have to certainly try to
do both things so try to avoid extreme
movements get a good physicians advice
what do you do next and how you
basically proceed but in general to
prevent that problem is perfectly
explained you really need to try to keep
a certain constant activity level which
is usually higher than what we usually
do in daily life it's a movement is a
key element in therapy but where do you
actually draw the line when is movement
not enough anymore and you need surgery
the the key element is trying to get a
balanced movement and the point is when
you need therapy or surgical
intervention is when basically is the
movement capacities are not any more
fully available for example if a muscle
is really degraded in such a mode that
it simply cannot end honestly regenerate
you're a researcher what do you do then
at the moment where we are really from
the lab directly what we're working on
is stem cell therapies that help us to
regenerate muscle tissue which usually
lent and to scar like tissue structures
and we would like to or what we are
doing is really initiate regeneration in
those muscle structures in model system
that works very nicely and we just now
entered a phase 1 2 clinical trial to
see how far we can really go and really
rescue muscle structures and avoid scar
tissue formation in patients and what do
you actually do how do you initiate it
how do you get the stem cells to the
right tissue it's actually very simple
basically we basically apply the stem
cells adjacent to the cut or ask our
area where we would like to avoid an
extension of scar tissue formation or
even try to prevent scar tissue
formation completely and it's a simple
delivery at those sites off to the
muscle and that seems to work very very
nicely
and I play through people especially who
had processes and we had surgery there
they might heal a lot faster afterwards
and avoid that they have a lack of
muscle capacity later on but it's
certainly if that proves as it looks at
the moment then it really provides a
basis for any other interventions for
example in the spine really where we
have larger muscle problems or where we
try to initiate regeneration even in
smaller muscle structures and what about
the bone structure is what about
vertebra and you also may be in use and
to help healing with bio medicine and
stem cells I mean there are a very good
first results of stem cells in bone
regeneration but it's not really widely
used we're working on getting that
really on a regular basis for example
coming with interpretive cell sorting
technologies that allow us to really
apply stem cells from that patient in
the side of injury or different strategy
would be off-the-shelf products and
that's one day in the far far future
you'll just substitute the whole spine
no I think that will never happen the
body is such a filaggrin nice general
structure highly balanced and highly
interactive what we can do is just
support the regenerative cascades in the
case where it's not happening otherwise
thanks a lot for the talk Georg do that
my pleasure